[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
tuesday and we watched a movie do we
have to talk about movie watch a good
one this is the second time i've seen
this one the first time i saw it
i remember liking it but i couldn't
remember much about it and i saw it
again the second time and [ __ ]
liked it a lot more this movie is way
ahead of his time
i mean it really was um
you can see how much uh night of the
living dead ripped this off yeah danny
rowling just said that uh in my opinion
george merritt definitely ripped off oh
yeah yeah yeah with the yeah i mean a
lot of the scenes he ripped off just
straight up you know like the porch
scenes i mean i don't know if i'd say
like ripped off because he did
acknowledge fire by that this was that
this was like an influence yeah because
honestly even though the monsters in the
last man on earth are technically
vampires
um the way that they act is kind of like
zombie-like yeah they're they're they're
george romero ghouls that they can talk
yeah they're just like not that bright
and like not their strong that not that
strong and they kind of like shamble
around
yeah and if they knew if they knew
somebody in life they'll call their name
but they don't seem to
have conversations per se they just come
back to your house calling you yeah
pretty much it sounds like that's kind
of which is something that old like old
school vampires used to do but i say
like in i mean in the book and in this
version of the movie which is the most
faithful to the novel
um
they're specifically like they have all
the trappings of vampires you know what
i mean like they're afraid of garlic and
they're afraid of their reflection
and you have to kill them with uh steaks
although i think that some of them get
shot later and they still die so maybe i
don't need the stakes to keep them dead
yeah that's right to keep him in the
grave that's right because he did that
to the dog
when the dog died that's right yeah he
left the steak the dog got vampires
well he was infected yeah he figured he
was like
and and watching it more closely i see
where uh the charlton heston's omega man
got a lot of its inspiration you know i
mean it is a retelling of this story
but a lot of the tropes were kind of
kind of [ __ ] continued on you know
they were improved on you know like uh
first of all they used his real name
like from the book neville
yeah in this version he they call him
robert morgan for some reason maybe they
thought neville was too weird to name it
yeah and in this one he was working on
the cure and he had a cure of blood and
it was in his blood because he got bit
by a bat earlier on in life when he was
down in central america
and it made him resistance to it
to this virus that it's a virus they're
uh their mutants when they come out and
they're kind of vampiric when they come
back
and um
he's got his own he's still living in
his house that he can't that he grew up
in or not grew up in but lived in with
his wife
it's all tricked up with like lines i
guess they're bells and booby traps and
[ __ ] everywhere
um mirrors and
the
they don't like the the the
the ghouls don't like their own
reflection and they don't like the smell
of garlic it makes them
it upsets them
so you know it is very much a vampire
vampire style
zombie
mutant
type thing but you can see where they
used all that and put it in uh omega man
now i'm gonna say her off the top i like
omega man better but i like this movie
too this movie is also good it's up
there with
like night of the living dead
maybe a little bit better and i feel
like this movie doesn't really get a lot
of credit
for being really influential yeah on the
zombie genre being influential on night
of living dead in particular before this
came out
i mean you had like some zombie movies
back in the 40s that were more like you
know haitian zombie type movies um and i
think that in the 50s maybe the late 50s
i think there were one or two sci-fi
movies that were kind of had to do with
aliens taking over corpses well i think
plan 9 from outer space did that and i
think there was another movie that did
that but this was kind of the first one
that had what you would recognize as
like a romero type zombie and this came
out like four years before living dead
yeah now on a side note
um
the uh the band rob zombie's first band
white zombie did a song um called like
an i am legend
all right
and it's me it's quoting the book
this movie and omega man all of it in
the same lyrics i [ __ ] love the song
and when you watch when you watch both
movies you can pick out what rob zombie
was talking about in some of those
lyrics he's he's meshing them together
but they're kind of homaging all three
the book the movie and and omega man
good song it's on youtube i am legend
i mean the thing about it is that i've
seen this movie a couple times but i
haven't seen it in a while
and watching it again i had forgotten
how one how close this was to the book
and two how different it was from omega
man i mean omega man
they kind of went they're it's similar
but they kind of went their own
direction with it they had like a bunch
of other [ __ ] going on um
this one
is pretty similar to the book the ending
is slightly different
but
that's about it i mean they changed a
couple things but not really anything i
mean richard matheson who wrote i am
legend which had come out
i think in the 50s
and he actually wrote the first
screenplay for this
but he didn't really like how the movie
was turning out
and so he still had to get credited so
he could get royalties so he credited he
was credited as logan swanson
on the thing but after he sort of like
turned in his thing and like the
directors kind of like fussed with it
well see what happened was originally
hammer was supposed to make this they
were supposed to do the adaptation
and then like there were some issues and
they couldn't end up making it so it's
supposed to be hammer was supposed to do
it and they told richard matheson that
fritz lang was gonna direct it of m and
metropolis fame and richard matheson was
jacked he was like yes that's gonna be
awesome uh but then they couldn't get
fritz lang or he wasn't gonna do it or
something like that and so the guy that
they ended up this actually has two
directors because it was shot in italy
like to be cheap uh so it's the whole
thing was shot in rome even though it's
supposed to be la
and so it has like an italian director
who doesn't have really that many
credits i think it's this one one like
one other movie and then like the other
guy the american director sydney
salkau
and he's kind of like he's done a [ __ ]
ton of movies mostly it seemed like when
i was looking at his imdb it mostly
seems like war movies like crime dramas
westerns he did a lot of stuff he did
some episodes of the adams family and
lassie and [ __ ] like that he did direct
um
twice told tales which also had vincent
bryce in it that came out of 1963 that
was like a horror anthology which was
three stories from like nathaniel
hawthorne and i've always kind of wanted
to see that i think it's free on amazon
prime because i've read all the stories
that it's based on but i don't think
i've ever seen it so
when that guy came on richard matheson
said something [ __ ] like oh well
that's a step down isn't it like from
fritz lang which i guess that's true but
he was so he was kind of mad about it so
that was kind of why he had uh his name
but he did say he didn't love the movie
but he did say that it was the most
faithful to his novel so he appreciated
that i thought it was good i like it too
i kind of feel like it didn't really get
i think it kind of got [ __ ] on at the
time a little bit like when it came out
in the 60s but i think time has been
kind of kind to it i don't love the over
over dubbing
um but because it was an italian
production that was just kind of what
they did
uh because you can tell that like a lot
of the people
overdubbed oh i i noticed it because it
to me it's just like another cheap movie
kind of like
night of living dead but the scope is a
little bit bigger
the first time i saw it was black and
white there's a colorized version you
can see for free now too yeah we watched
the colorized version it was um amazon
prime right
it was yeah it was it was freev which i
guess is like free with ads like if
you're on amazon prime yeah so we
watched it free without you but it was
the colorizer yeah yeah it's worth
seeing if you like not a living dead and
omega man hell yeah you want to see it
it's good um
there is there is differences between
the two
but they're just kind of different
interpretations between
the two movies like for instance
and i am legend
the basic
the basic um
uh mutant is like a a george romero
zombie
but they can talk a little bit and they
have vampire type features
but later on in the movie you find out
that there are other ones
that are like normal humans that have it
but they're resistant to it
and they were in this
they had kind of come up with a halfway
cure to keep them from flipping over all
the way
and
in in the charlton heston version they
have that it's called the family all
right which is very similar but they're
kind of like different interpretations
for the time in this one they're more
like fascists they're wearing like
mussolini fascists they're all in black
um they're kind of paramilitary looking
and they're trying to form a new country
a country based on damn vampires i guess
and they well they're all that's left
they're all that's left so and there's
they see um they see vincent price as
kind of like a relic of the past and
that he's evil he's going around killing
all these other people who turned into
zombies and some of them were still
alive when he killed him they hadn't
even turned yet he was still killed so
so that's that
they see him as a monster so they were
afraid of they were afraid of him yeah
okay and charlton heston one instead of
them being mussolini fascists they're
more like antifa and they're
eco-terrorists they're doing it because
mankind they're destroying all
technology and the memory of man and
trying to burn and all they're burning
all the books and because they're saying
that man destroyed the earth and he's
got he had risen himself above with his
arrogance and his science and they're
going to make everything right and
everyone's equal now they're we're all
the same color because they all turn
into damn
uh in in they all they all go albino in
in in omega man so you can see how they
kind of changed it for the times you
know the main [ __ ] because uh omega
man was late 60s early 70s when they
came out with that
and it was kind of like something you
would see from like anti-war protesters
uh you know in a certain aspect that's
kind of how the there's antifa basically
that's what the family was
um but they didn't show any other kind
of
zombies or whatever you want to call
them mutants and that one never mutants
just those they're just the family and i
i thought it was handled well i thought
it was handled real well in both movies
although you said the first one is
closer to the book
way way closer
[Music]
with ruth like the the woman that was
infected but they had this sort of like
partial vaccine
that you could take it and it would kind
of like stave off but it wasn't you had
to like keep injecting yourself with it
yeah um the situation with her was
slightly different like she ended up
escaping and at the end of the book
he he doesn't get killed but they're
about to execute him you know what i
mean
and i think in the book too it was
slightly bleaker because in in the movie
he's kind of like oh his blood it could
cure her
and he's like oh well we'll go and you
know we'll cure all the people and then
they end up killing him
so they don't get the blood yeah they
still have their own cure but it's not
perfect you know it's so temporary but
in the book um there isn't a cure like
there's a temporary cure but his blood
doesn't care anymore
and both movies kind of handle his death
the same way there's kind of a religious
motif kind of the crucifixion and then
they get the blood or they don't get the
blood
in the in
in the charlton heston version they get
his blood so there's hope for the future
yeah so they made the ending more
hopeful whereas this one has a more
bleak ending just like the book had
right like i said he you know spoiler
alert for a movie that's from 1964. but
vincent price gets killed at the end of
this yeah and um and in the book it's
implied that he's gonna get killed
because he's about to be executed like
that's when the book ends but as i said
in the book
his blood doesn't cure anything it's not
like so that was added like into the
[ __ ] later
but
as i said i had forgotten how
different omega man was from the book
and i mean i've read the book like a
couple of times it's been a while but
a mega man does not have as many
flashbacks into the into the
pre-pandemic
yeah last month on earth
it's you it sets up the world like
everyone's dead vincent price is the
only guy left and it kind of shows like
his daily routine like what happened to
his wife
well wait a minute like i'm talking
about like present day oh okay because
it's because this movie came out in 1964
but
the part of it that's not flashback is
supposed to be 1968. yeah so it's in the
future for their point of view it's
right futuristic so they show what his
daily routine is now that the world's
gone to [ __ ] and everyone's dead yeah it
died in 65 1965 yeah which which is
relevant to the [ __ ] white zombie
album night because he quoted 1965 all
the time because a lot of [ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] happened in 1965 and
[ __ ] rob zombie's mind
so anyway so um
so yeah so it's just showing his daily
thing like he gets up he makes stakes
for the day he has this big map because
he's looking for the nest where like all
the vampires sleep during the day
because he wants to like wipe them all
out at once so he's been doing like a
grid system like going around the
killing whatever once he finds and he's
trying to like find where the where the
bulk of them are
so he's just shown like driving around
all day like getting gas doing [ __ ] like
that he takes some like vampires that he
kills and there's like a big pit and
they puts him in the pit and like burns
him and [ __ ] like that and then at night
all of the vampires not all of them but
like you know some of them including
like his a guy that was his buddy like
before was his co-worker before the
pandemic happened comes to sort of like
morgan come out you know we got funny
voices yeah well i mean he's pretty much
the only one that talks yeah
i mean his wife talks when she comes
back but yeah but after that like after
they set everything up and they
established that he's kind of like
losing his marbles because it's been
three years and he's hasn't seen another
person and he's just been doing this
like every day mega man was like that
too and then and then it jumps back into
like a very long flashback where it's
showing you what it was like like when
when the pandemic happened and like when
it was getting really bad and like you
know they're trying to oh it'll be okay
they'll figure something out and he's
like trying to work on the cure in the
lab and [ __ ] like that and then
everybody gets in that his daughter gets
it and then his wife gets it and it's
just like it's really horrific so i kind
of like the way they did that but it's
like the flashbacks are
it's not like they're grizzly too
they are pretty grizzly i mean
society collapsing it's good
post-apocalyptic b-movie fun
but it's kind of dark you know what i
mean the [ __ ] that happens they're
taking people before they're dead and
killing them it seems like it's implied
that his daughter was still alive when
they took her yeah they don't say that
outright but
he comes back home because the daughter
was sick and he's like you can't call a
doctor you can't call anybody because
they'll come and get her because you
know they're quarantining everybody and
they're killing the the people that have
it
and uh he comes back from it and the
people had come and taken the daughter
and so he runs down to the pit and he's
like where's my daughter at like looking
at all the trucks and everything and the
guy just says to him it's like yeah a
lot of people's daughters are down there
including mine yeah my daughter's down
there too
and
i thought that was a great touch it's
like you know the authorities were
weren't necessarily the bad guys all of
society was [ __ ] falling apart they
were i mean they were just trying they
were scrambling
yeah trying to stop this trying to stop
it but it was like too late by the time
that they because they figured out
weren't they like talking earlier about
how it was airborne and like they
weren't really fast and [ __ ] like that
and it seemed like hardly anybody was
immune yeah it was good apocalyptic
low budget i mean i mean for for this
how low the budget is you could buy it i
go okay because you're driving around in
empty cities you know empty parts of the
city
uh [ __ ] you know kind of bombed out
and dirt you know places are kind of
[ __ ] pillaged you know and empty
supermarkets so i think they did a good
job for the budget you know it yeah i
mean a dog just running up and he's like
hey dog you know just in the dog running
away you know just like oh [ __ ]
that's just kind of
which was some of the elements of the
omega man that i like that kind of quiet
still you know there's nobody around
you're in a big city it's falling apart
it's got pretty cool he's basically
doing urban exploration urban yeah like
urbex video but you don't have to worry
about getting arrested yeah which is
nice yeah there's no authorities or
anything
in a way and i i kind of feel like
that's probably why a lot of people like
post-apocalyptic stories that's one of
the reasons that i like them yeah
because i'm just sitting there going
because i'm like man like the the zombie
vampires um christian zombie vampire the
zombie vampire is like [ __ ] up his car
and then he's like man then he just like
walks down to the phone another car and
gets another one yeah so i was just like
wow that's gotta be cool you could just
he just like walks in the grocery store
and like picks up whatever he needs
because he still had the grocery store
that was near him still had a big
generator and he was like keeping it
running so there was still like meetings
so he'd been keeping it running for like
three years so he still had like the
refrigeration kind of [ __ ] in the back
it was like there was hanging beef in
there and he was that's where he was
keeping the garlic fresh yeah and [ __ ]
like that to keep the vampires away yeah
when i first saw omega man um that's
what kind of what got me was the scene
where charlton heston wrecks his car
and goes into a dealership and talks to
just like a fake oh this is i love the
color
he's got a [ __ ] smith wesson mk 760
sub machine gun and with a flashlight on
it which was high-tech a diving light
it's high tech back in the day he just
gasses it up and run smashes it right
out through the damn
storefront window and [ __ ] goes home
in it and as a kid
you know growing up right outside of la
and long beach
i could recognize where he was and it
was just mind-blowing you know like wow
you know i was trying to grasp
what that would be like an empty los
angeles
you know yeah i liked it but that's kind
of what got me into the omega man at an
early age i just played it on television
a lot when i was a kid and then i i
didn't know about this one until you
told it told me about a few years ago
yeah when i saw it the first time i saw
i was like yeah it's pretty good but on
a second viewing it's it's better much
better i think it might be one where
it seems to be very rewatchable and you
probably notice more and appreciate it
more with each viewing
because i appreciated it more on the
second viewing
yeah it's definitely one that needs and
like i said it definitely seemed like
because it was so low budget and i think
it kind of got [ __ ] on a lot even
richard matheson was just kind of like
hey he didn't love it he thought that
directing was what he called inept
um
but
i think time has kind of been kind to it
it's not bad and honestly this movie
only came out 10 years after the book
was published it's as good as night of
the living dead
yeah and as good as that and it's sad
because much like knight of living dead
this movie is also in the public domain
yeah okay uh so
yeah i don't i don't know what the [ __ ]
it's as good as like night of living
dead but i would say they're offering
different things and night of the living
dead the acting is a lot better the main
hero is love even though well you say
the main hero in this one is vincent
price he does a great job too yeah it's
just a different story it's more like
you know
survival against mindless hordes in
night living dead this one there's a
little
there's more to it than that
some of them some of the zombies are
like that but they're inept and they're
weak yeah it's not it's not so much that
he's not really worried that much about
this he's not scared of him i mean he's
not scared of them because like they
can't really get in because they're kind
of stupid and they're kind of weak and
stuff like and you can push them just
push them the hell out of you just push
them over and and he's just they're not
going he's going crazy trying to kill
them all
right yeah and he's
he's searching the cities through grids
trying to find out where their nest is
and how to kill them all and he's trying
to get rid of all of them he doesn't
have any idea that some of them are half
human basically or human and he feels
bad like when when the woman that he
meets like tells him yeah she's like
some of those people hadn't even weren't
even dead yeah
and it's like i'm a murderer right well
that's where the [ __ ] title i am
legend comes from he's a legend to those
[ __ ] half vampire people just the way
that vampires were the legends these are
humans yeah prior to right [ __ ] taking
over yeah
they don't really i don't know they
don't really explain i mean it is kind
of like it's a virus essentially is what
it is or a bacteria it's a pandemic that
makes it kills you and you come back
like the ghouls from night living dead
and but you have a lot of vampire ways
as you can say yeah and i mean in the
book i think they were like a little bit
faster like they could run and stuff
um but yeah in this you can totally see
where george romero got that and i feel
like i feel like enough people don't
really like talk about that
i mean you know i'm not saying night of
the living dead wasn't a masterpiece and
that it was like groundbreaking stuff it
was
i'm just saying that this movie
was really influential on night of the
living dead and i don't know if a lot of
people know that because i feel like a
lot of people maybe haven't seen it well
like you said i i feel like the omega
man a lot of people like you had seen
that a bunch of times and i feel like a
lot of people have seen that but i
didn't even i don't know
how common knowledge it is that this was
the first adaptation of richard
novel i didn't know about it it's good i
like the uh
towards the end when you find out that
there's a damn nazi not a nazi a vampire
army
yeah and when they show them
they're all in black they look like
mussolini's black shirts kind of they're
kind of futuristic
for the you know for the situation and
they're all running around with m1 grand
rifles and and uh submachine guns
look like
swedish case of machine guns and you got
to fight him
he's fighting him they got submachine
guns all he has is some homemade smoke
grenades to try to make doesn't he steal
some [ __ ] from an armory armory like
while he's running away from him yeah he
did he did some stuff but i got to go
back and see it again it kind of
happened kind of fast
i looked away a couple times when i
looked back something else happened but
he he
he
he ends up getting killed he runs into a
church and they kill him
in front of everybody and ruth is like
kind of trying this like she's trying to
stop him because she's like hey his
blood is like a cure
you know what i mean like i said they
had a partial cure but it was just
temporary so i mean he he injected her
like he gave her a transfusion of his
blood while she was like knocked out and
it seemed to cure her like
across the board like she was okay again
she was human again but
kaylan higgins says does the horde still
spread through bites or open wounds in
last man on earth they don't really
specify i think near the beginning they
talk about the virus being airborne and
they're saying they're hoping that it's
not because it will spread faster but i
thought the implication was that it was
airborne because it spread so quickly
you know what i mean
yeah um
they don't seem to eat anybody they
attack people but they don't seem to eat
them i mean somebody said to him i think
somebody like the the co-worker of his
what was his name ben or whatever his
name was um
i think he said something about oh they
won't drink my blood or something like
that they drink your blood i'm not sure
but i'm not sure if he said that because
this was kind of before
everything went to [ __ ] it was just kind
of like partially the weight of [ __ ] and
he was saying well they're technically
vampires and vincent price like the
vampires don't exist what are you
talking about that's supernatural [ __ ]
but he's like yeah well if it walks like
a duck and quacks like a duck it's a
[ __ ] vampire so i don't know if he
was saying that they literally drank
people's blood or if he was just saying
that because oh maybe they drink
people's blood because they you know act
like vampires otherwise yeah but they do
seem to like attack people but i don't
really know
they don't like bite them or anything
like that i don't think they just got
clubs they just swing [ __ ] pieces of
boards and [ __ ] they're just like
[ __ ] up your house and [ __ ] up
your [ __ ] car [ __ ] your car now when
ruth ran out the house they attacked her
the vampires did but i couldn't tell if
they were trying to bite her or if they
were just doing something else
they just showed up with a bunch of two
by fours and we're swinging them things
around they've busted up his car and
they're slow
yeah and then um he goes out during the
day to try to kill him and there'll be
dead ones laying out because if he gets
caught out in the sunlight it kills them
yeah
again they'll be laying there dead
then he doesn't care then he has to
throw them all in the back of the
station wagon and take him to the pit
right so they don't like
attract insects or whatever the hell but
i'm guessing like other animals got the
[ __ ] too because you know he seemed like
when he saw the dog
he was like really really happy like
you're alive you're alive yeah so i
guess it killed off a lot of the animals
as well
so
that's kind of sucks because i guess you
can't really hunt animals then
like if it killed all the
khan says he's never seen the version
from the 60s oh it's free go see it it's
good good yeah it's in the public domain
so you can see it pretty much anywhere
yeah um like i said it's pretty low
budget but
i think you'll be surprised at how close
it is to the living dead and it's easily
i mean still of the three adaptations of
i am legend i mean this is easily the
closest to the book it follows the book
almost exactly there's like a couple of
things that it changed but that's about
it like the ending is slightly different
and a couple little details are
different i appreciate both versions
uh i like the charlene heston version
better i like a mega man better just as
a movie more happens in it it's a little
a little bit more modern but i i still
like this one i'd like it
in the way that you like to see not you
know
uh not a living dead about like that
a little more complicated a little more
complicated story than night of living
dead so instead of like instead of pure
like horror and people getting eaten and
[ __ ] like that and just like that
oppressive fear trapped in the house
it's a little it's got it's taking place
at a bigger scale he leaves the house he
goes places
uh you know there are characters
uh that are not human in it you know
it's good you know i don't say they're
not human they're infected talking you
know yeah and it shows more about how
the pandemic and the army what they did
and you know how his wife went nuts and
it shows all that yeah like how the
daughter got sick and how the wife got
sick and then he
um
you know him not wanting to
i guess like he didn't want the same
thing to happen to his wife that
happened to his daughter like getting
tossed in the fire pit so when his wife
died of the virus he just buried her and
that's when he figured out that they oh
they come back like from the dead
because he just buried her and she
came back to the house she was like
robert
came back to the house that was like
pretty creepy actually
so he ended up having to like stake her
and then he put her like in a church and
like under a coffin and stuff like that
and he would go back to visit her so i
kind of feel like i like that they did
the long flashbacks though of like what
happened before that i feel like a mega
man didn't do that as much
um because it gave a lot more context
and you know you didn't i think it would
have been different like if you had just
had vincent price like just the whole
time like going nuts like living by
himself you know what i mean so i like
that they had those long flashbacks like
with him with his family and it gave
like more context and texture to the
story i think like i said it's very it's
very low budget it's american
international pictures um you know i
would have actually would have loved to
see hammer get hold of this um because
it probably would have been cool but i
really did like how this turned out
vincent price is great in it
you know it's over dubbed and that kind
of bothers me but
other than that um yeah i really like
this one i like this one because it's
the most faithful book i like omega man
too i love that movie yeah but they took
a lot of liberties yeah in omega man but
that's okay it's its own thing you know
amazing yeah sly if you haven't seen
this movie see it if you like night of
living dead you'd like this they're in
there fighting about what was better
this one or night of the living dead
night of living dead is more iconic they
have more of an impact
okay
they're both good movies
i'd probably say not a living dead is
probably a better movie um yeah i don't
think anybody would argue yeah i'd say
probably a better movie but the thing is
is that after you've seen night of
living dead so many times you get sick
of watching the same movie a lot you can
go to this one and it's
it's kind of the same play on that it's
a cross between 911 dead and omega man
like it's happening in the same movie
yeah i mean some of the scenes in this
yeah are very similar to the scene that
would later turn up in night of the
living dead yeah but like i said i'm
pretty sure george romero he didn't like
try to be sneaky about it and then he
basically they were nigh living deb was
ripping this movie off
pretty much but it's okay that's a good
job
like i said he admitted it yeah so they
admitted it right
he said well yeah he's like that was my
inspiration
though it might have improved it a bit
yeah but they're both low budget movies
you know
so
this one inspired them to make said well
[ __ ] they can make that movie then i can
make night of living dead for less
you know [ __ ] there you go they did
it
and i well and in a way i mean this one
is more i think impressive in terms of
low budget because bigger scope it's a
yeah it has a bigger scope i mean
obviously they shot it in rome and they
had to shoot these big like empty
streets and stuff and i think they did a
really good job you know yeah they're
wrong
that's why they look like [ __ ]
mussolini's fascists then yeah okay all
right yeah well they shot it in rome
yeah okay because it was cheaper yeah
even though the book is supposed to be
it's the book is l.a yeah and i'm
imagining that the movie was supposed to
be la but they didn't really say words i
thought it was it was no it's wrong you
picked places that did kind of look like
la though well yeah that's probably the
way they did that because that's where
the book was at with los angeles a lot
of people don't know that that that
italy looks like california okay yeah
that's why all the spaghetti westerns
when they're doing old west flicks they
did that out in the italian desert
because it looked like southern
california out there yeah it's like
about the same
[Laughter]
yeah they're talking about uh kanavatsan
says he hasn't seen this version or the
omega man oh man go ahead and check off
although
although he did see the will smith
version of those endings
the the will smith version they [ __ ]
it up bad because the the the mutants
didn't talk
and the outbreak was not global
okay it was just in a city
and you've got you you [ __ ] up the
movie then and lin would fly off i said
the will smith version was too much cgi
room yeah yeah i didn't really like the
way the mutants looked and yeah i didn't
like a lot about that one
the whole premise of the original story
is that this man is the last man on
earth he's a legend
the other people are not men anymore
they're monsters and they are scared of
him and he is this legendary monster
running around killing him yeah because
he's killing killing them yeah they
sleep so it is so it's an inversion yeah
it is a global [ __ ] pademic the whole
world is [ __ ] gone just these few
survivors and most of them are mutants
and this one dude who is immune to it
and he's a monster for them
and that omega man's exactly that same
thing now there are a couple of other
people in omega man that had a limited
resistance to it which that happens in
this one too
but it's a different there's two
different form two different versions of
the partly immune in a mega man most
people just died
immediately other ones were turned into
basically
psychopathic albinos who were [ __ ]
crazy all right and they were like eco
terrorists and antifa
combined together trying to kill the
last white man it was his fault
him and his [ __ ] accursed
technology and all of his science that
destroyed the earth you know what i mean
so they're going after him and then
there was another group
of people that were infected but they
never quite flipped
they were still human but they were
infected
they would flip but they flipped a lot
slowly
so
you know mega man kind of maybe has had
a little bit more of a real more
medical realism maybe something like
that might happen they were partially
resistant to it
it's a good move they're both great
movies
but uh for kahn of ozlon i would watch
omega man first
and then you can go back and watch this
one too i like a mega man out of the two
i'd rather like i like a mega man she
probably likes this one
yeah just well because i love this
morning i love the book and this one is
not exactly accurate but it is way more
accurate than the omega manas yeah um
hugo says are you gonna review i am
legend at some point yeah next like the
the will smith
yeah i wouldn't mind doing that one
because i saw it one time and did not
care for it yeah um but i'm willing to
give it another shot because it's been a
while since i've seen it maybe it's not
as bad as i remembered somebody
mentioned that there's that there's an
alternate ending and the alternate
ending is better than the theater yeah a
lot of people have said that because the
i think i saw the theatrical version i
see that in the theater maybe i did
um
i feel like the theatrical version i was
ending i was just kind of like nope my
my problem with the movie when i saw it
was that it wasn't a global pandemic
and he wasn't the last man there were
people on the outside that were helping
him he had radio contact with him it was
just in the city yeah it's like so that
like negates the whole entire point of
the book the whole entire point of the
book why it's called i am legend like i
said it's inverting right you know in
the original story it was vampires it's
inverting like oh vampires are a legend
to humans but now everyone's vampires so
he's the legend
to them like because they're the only
ones left and there's they're making the
new society and then the monsters
in will smith version were basically
rage zombies that's all reuted out rage
zombies which they probably got from
2018 yeah and they you know
so there goes there's no chances of
having any characters
you know it should have been more like
something out of a mega man a cult of
mutants
that [ __ ]
saw
that saw a [ __ ] neville like like out
of a mega man they saw him as a relic of
the past that had to go and it was all
his fault
you know so
that would have made it for a much more
interesting movie yeah i think i mean in
last man on earth they don't really like
imply that they think it's his fault
it's just that they're scared of him
right and kind of rightly so because
like i said some of those people were
still alive and he was just going around
like killing them with impunity you know
mega man it was his fault though he made
that pandemic yeah but in last minute on
earth it wasn't yeah he made that
pandemic he was a military scientist who
made that bio weapon and got out and he
was able to give himself the
experimental cure
and was going to disseminate it but the
helicopter was in got shot down or
crashed somehow i forgot why and you
know what's weird i think in the
original book if i'm and this might be
another change i don't think he was a
scientist in the book i think he was
just a dude that worked at a factory or
something like that like just a random
guy
mega man was an amalgamation of a bunch
of concepts i guess from that first
movie he had the book because he was a
scientist in the movie yeah and he's a
scientist in this one too yeah in last
minute earth also yeah that's what i
meant he's a scientist
in this movie and he was a scientist in
in you know mega man too yeah
yeah dan uh linwood said i've seen night
of living dead a thousand times and last
man omegaman did not care for vincent's
black and white version if it was in
color possibly like more yeah the the
version that's on um
amazon prime i think if you go on amazon
prime it's called freebie um they have
both they have the black and white
version and the colorized version yeah
the colorized version was good yeah i
didn't mind it actually i mean every
time i've seen it before i've seen it in
black and white but the colorized
version actually looks pretty good i
think
but yeah so
you know if you haven't seen it go check
it out especially if you're in night of
living dead you can be like oh that's
where george got that idea and we're
gonna be talking about omega man soon
and also read the book because the book
is really really good i mean that's it's
a [ __ ] iconic horror novel of the
20th century so everybody should read it
um i actually read all of richard maths
and stuff because all his stuff is
amazing all right so i guess what's it
it's tuesday right yeah all right so
tomorrow is our big main show
and because we had a tie
in the patreon poll and because the tie
was between two things that are
paranormal i just dies [ __ ] it we're
going to talk about them both on one
show so we're going to talk about
uh is it husqva castle or houska castle
that place in the czech republic that
you know they say is like a you know
over the
doorway to hell or whatever uh so we're
going to talk about that and we're going
to do like sort of a revisit sort of
thing of the doris bither
uh entity
case the haunting case yeah
i gotta talk to pat real quick he said i
saw the group and omega man as a cult
well what the [ __ ] do you think they
were yeah they're occult they were
called but they were occult of [ __ ]
um
mutants they were all
uh
albinos and they were psychopaths and
drove them crazy and they had taken over
the last vestiges of government they
were living in in um
city hall
and they had put on religious robes and
stuff because they were kind of like
a religious order to stamp out it was
kind of like the inquisition and and
they were kind of like eco-terrorists
and they were they were just and they
were like antifa they were like
everything all just put in together go
back and listen to what they say you'll
recognize that you hear people talking
that way now
that's a good movie
kind of onslaught says jenny have you
ever done the blind dead series by
armada diasorio i haven't but i have all
of them like somebody sent them to me
like in the big coffin box uh so yeah
i'll get around to them uh eventually
but yeah so thanks for dropping by today
hopefully we'll see you guys for our big
paranormal show tomorrow that should be
really fun
uh so yeah thanks everybody for dropping
by we'll see you guys tomorrow evening
bye